I am sure you get this a lot from time
to time what part of that was true the
whole thing besides the dialogue and
then of course her nickname at the end
for me ducky hammers is obviously but a
nickname since I was a child yeah and an
embarrassing incident happened in
swimming lessons where I lost my bathing
suit and people have called whenever
it's not the worst end to that story no
it's true people see a big ole are you
seeing somebody now I do yeah I'm seeing
someone it's like a long distance oh
yeah yep where where are they she lives
in Nashville and I live in New York and
people always find out about it they're
like oh those never go the way you want
them to and I was get really nervous I
think oh my god yeah she might move here
like it's so it's nerve-wracking that's
like a perfect joke yeah have you ever
been attracted to like an older woman
no I haven't better draggers an older
woman but my roommate in New York City
is 75 years old sorry
my roommate yeah she's 75 is she aware
you're there see from time to time she's
obsessed I'm Canadian uh-huh and she's
obsessed that I'm Canadian and we have
free health care and she tells everyone
in the building that I'm her friend with
benefits so it's it's hard it's hard for
me some classic
thank you